para hablar de un caso bien polémico no
a la basquetbolista estadounidense
brittney griner acusada en rusia de
posesión y contrabando de drogas se
declaró ayer jueves culpable ante un
tribunal en moscú la capital rusa la
deportista que se dio de un traductor
durante la sesión del tribunal de jinky
admitió todos los carros aunque señaló
que no tenía la intención de cometer un
delito es que ryanair explicó la
presencia de aceite de cannabis en su
equipaje debido al apuro con el que
empacó sus maletas para poder viajar a
rusia precisamente antes de que
comenzara esta invasión nuestro segundo
invitado del día le damos la bienvenida
al es antonio quintero abogado
especialista en derecho del deporte
internacional y por supuesto está
nuestra cronista deportiva en mares a el
mar bienvenida también a este segmento
de nuestro invitado el día muchísimas
gracias por la invitación para estar acá
también vamos a comenzar el mar y
antonio pues hablando de que es un tema
político no más allá de lo deportivo
pues muchísimo personas señalan que está
haciendo
gryner usada como una ficha política
para luego puede tener un tipo de
conversaciones con washington a lo mejor
para una rebaja de sanciones pues
antonio que le parece todo este caso
digamos y cuál es su primera impresión
al respecto
bueno muchísimas gracias por estar aquí
por la invitación y por compartir con
humano una persona que admiro mucho y
quería decirles que el caso se basa en
que esta atleta
directamente fue encontrada con
posición de unos cartuchos para el bei
de
cannabis una semana antes de que
comenzara la guerra de rusia con ucrania
teniendo en cuenta esta situación ella
está siendo procesada acusada de el uso
de larga escala o especialmente de larga
escala de narcóticos y posición para uso
personal que de acuerdo al artículo 228
del código penal de rusia esto puede
tener una sanción que va desde tres
meses hasta diez años a ella se le
encontraron aproximadamente una posición
de 0.7 gramos de cannabis en sus vips y
directamente lo que dice el código
criminal es que cuando se entiende que
uno utiliza de una
el 10 o sea cuando una dosis
multiplicada por 10 es lo que tú tienes
en posesión ya se habla de larga escala
y las acciones hasta tres meses y cuando
es 50 veces el tamaño de una dosis ya
estamos hablando de de larga escala y
por lo tanto ahí es que sube la sanción
a de 3 a 10 años
nuevamente pareciera un caso político
pero también tiene una parte legal que
había que explicar y bueno simplemente
para aclarar esta primera parte la
perspectiva de brittney griner antonio
no no es no parece buena a juzgar por la
tendencia en tribunales rusos de que las
absoluciones son apenas 1% de los casos
que se presentan y que pueden ser
revocadas
sí exactamente entonces ahí pasamos al
estudio y la estrategia legal no en este
sentido la primera parte de la
estrategia legal fue directamente
vincular este caso con lo que está
ocurriendo entre rusia y ucrania y decir
que esto es una cuestión política por
otro lado el gobierno de rusia yo no he
visto que ha hecho una gran campaña para
decir que no lo es entonces podemos
entender que ambas partes están de
acuerdo con eso segundo la segunda parte
de la estrategia de ella es declararse
culpable justamente porque yo ya sabe
que no tiene opción de ganar por este
porcentaje que está diciendo un mar
entonces como en una posible intercambio
de personas lo primero que rusia va a
pedir es declararse culpable ya ella
salió de eso lo tercero muy importante
de parte de ella es el hecho de que está
diciendo si soy culpable pero no lo hice
con intención se mezclaron estos
frasquitos en la ropa y por eso estaban
en la maleta esto que se utiliza para
rebajar las penas lo máximo posible
porque no es lo mismo cometer un crimen
con la intención de cometer el crimen
que por negligencia entonces por aquí va
ya está empezando la estrategia legal de
ella
claro antonio también el presidente
giovanni habló con su familia habló con
la esposa de esta atleta expresándole su
apoyo sin embargo del lado de greiner
digamos de su familia y sus familiares
más cercanos y su esposa también incluso
dicen que a lo mejor si fuera hombre y
si fuera una reconocida figura
mundialmente el baloncesto masculino
pues historia hubiera sido diferente a
lo mejor no estuviera procesada a lo
mejor ya hubiera movido todas las fichas
o posibles para que ésta esta persona no
llegara a la cárcel
digamos como esta diferencia que hay
entre hombres y mujeres y la visibilidad
que tienen los hombres y mujeres en el
deporte se puede también en este caso ir
por ese lado
bueno lo cierto es que si hay un
favoritismo a los hombres en el deporte
es sin duda alguna no lo vamos a negar
pero también recuerda que hay toda una
estrategia legal y que a veces sacar
esta carta a la discriminación se hace
para presionar también al gobierno
americano porque porque se está
estimando de que un intercambio de
prisioneros por decirlo así en este
momento no va a pasar en un momento
pronto entonces de esta forma es una
presión más para el gobierno de piden
para que busquen otras formas de
intercambio y la atleta pueda regresar
sana y salva a los eeuu recientemente
sea ahora que menciona antonio el tema
del intercambio de prisioneros
se ha especulado sobre la posibilidad de
que digamos una moneda de canje por la
libertad o el regreso de eeuu de
brittney griner podría ser el traficante
de armas viktor bout que tan está
sentenciado en eeuu a 25 años de cárcel
que tan factible es que se produzca en
este momento y a la luz de lo que se ha
visto un intercambio como éste
bueno esto es una pregunta más política
y que se sale de mi área porque tendría
que conocer un poco cuál es la situación
de esta persona pero al fin y al cabo la
respuesta termina siendo en esta
conclusión en eeuu ya obtuvo todo lo que
puede este prisionero cuál es el interés
fuerte en tener este prisionero por
parte de los eeuu y si todavía ellos
mantienen el interés y el interés es muy
fuerte obviamente que no va a ocurrir en
el intercambio pronto o por esta atleta
en este sentido ya que pareciera ser que
esta persona tiene un interés
directamente político en tener esta
fuerte ficha de cambio del lado de eeuu
entonces todo depende de la fuerza aquí
de esta persona y si yo obtuvieron todos
los resultados con esa persona antonio
también le quiero preguntar cómo están
las cosas y digamos legalmente en cuanto
a las leyes de moscú y también pues cómo
es el gobierno no del presidente ruso
vladimir putin cuánto tiempo se pudiera
demorar digamos para que ya se le haga
un juicio como tal a esta atleta está
unida y cuánto tiempo podríamos estar
digamos hablando hasta que se resuelva
finalmente este caso
bueno como todos los juicios sabemos
cómo empiezan pero no cuándo terminan
entiendo que la próxima audiencia
el 14 de julio si mal no recuerdo ya
básicamente el procedimiento debería ser
un procedimiento expedito con teniendo
en cuenta que ella se declaró culpable
entonces simplemente deberíamos pasar a
argumentar sobre mente sobre la pena
estamos hablando de que esto debería
pasar en menos de seis meses ya debería
haber una decisión aproximadamente y la
discusión es simplemente que pena va a
merecer ella viendo el contexto del caso
por eso es que brittany trainer declaró
de que había que era culpable de
tenerlos los frasquitos pero que no lo
hizo con intención ella está por todos
los lados buscando rebajar la pena lo
más posible entendiendo de que no hay
forma de que ella gane el caso
completamente entonces la idea es en qué
porcentaje el hogar entonces ahí empieza
la discusión son tres meses son seis
meses son tres años son diez años ese es
más o menos la discusión que se plantea
a partir de las declaraciones británicas
en ayer declarándose culpable culpable
de forma excepcional